And the first category
is party animal.
- Oh, wow.
- Party animal.
- These are artists
with an animal in their name.
- Oh, all right.
- Okay.
- Ariana, you're going
to start it off.
Let's get
the table in position.
- Perfect.
- Come on, everybody,
let's do this.
- Ready? On your mark,
get set, go!
- Come on.
Oh, oh, my gosh,
he's one of the greatest
rappers ever, legend.
Oh, my God, he's not a cat,
but a--
And he's now a kind of lion
of some sort.
- Snoop Dogg!
- Yes!
Fantastic!
[cheers and applause]
- Yes, you did it!
- All right.
This group has John,
Paul, Ringo--
- Beatles!
- Yes.
- Yeah! Very nice!
You can toss it on the ground.
[cheers and applause]
- Okay, these things
swim underwater.
- Sharks, fish--
- No--yes!
- Phish!
- Oh, very nice!
Phish.
- Oh, she's Texan.
She's a rapper.
She's--
- Megan Thee Stallion.
- Yeah!
- Wow!
- I love you!
- All right. Hurry up,
time is running out.
- Oh, my God, he's the one--
oh, no, no, no, no,
I don't have it. Can I skip it?
- All right. You can skip it.
- Okay. Oh, he was in 'NSYNC,
and he also was a fish,
but whatever this fish--
it's a fish--
oh, he was an astronaut--
- An astronaut?
- Yes!
[laughter]
[audience groaning]
- An astronaut?
What?
- Lance Bass.
[laughter]
- Lance Bass?
- His name is Lance Base.
His name is Lance Base.
- Bass!
That is 5,000 points
right there.
- Wait, hold on.
[cheers and applause]
- We got a new rack of records.
- What's the one
you threw away?
- Oh, no, no, no, no, no,
we're not talking about it.
Wait. Can I just--
can we verify one thing?
- Yes.
- Was Lance Bass not going to
be an astronaut at once point?
- No going to--he wasn't an
astronaut, but he was going--
He wanted to go to space,
right?
- Okay, so I'm not--
- It doesn't matter.
His name is Lance Base.
- She said fish.
- It's Lance Base,
everybody knows that.
- It's Lance Bass.
He sings the bass.
- I'm sorry.
I'm not good at games.
I'm just happy to be here.
[laughter]
- You were great!
We knew that, we knew that.
- Ariana, you're great.
Stop that. You're so good.
- This is the weakest link.
- Don't let them
get in your head.
Don't let them get
in your head.
- Let's get to round two
[overlapping chatter]
- You are the weakest link.
- Stop it, stop it.
[laughter]
Come on, Ari, here we go.
- Okay.
- This time,
the category is body of work.
These are artists whose names
contain parts of the body.
- Oh, wait.
[laughter]
- Kelly, you're going
to start this off.
Let's get the table
in position.
- What?
Oh, God, okay.
- You got this.
- Yeah!
- As soon as I pull it away,
you're going to start.
Are you ready?
- Okay.
- One, two, begin.
[applause]
Oh, I'm an all-star,
get your game on, get laid--
- ♪ [singing indistinctly]
- Oh, if I'm going to--
I don't want to--
I'm going to, I'm going to--
and then this is my--
- Smash Mouth.
- Yes!
- There you go!
- Come on.
Ariana, you got this!
- Oh, come on.
Okay, so it's a length
and then a part of your finger.
- What?
- A length and then
a part of the finger.
[laughter]
It's not--it's not--
- Nine Inch Nails!
- Yes!
- Wow, yes! That's right!
[cheers and applause]
- Okay,
he wrote with L.A. Reid.
He wrote for Toni Braxton.
- Babyface!
- Yes.
- Yes!
- Oh, nice.
[cheers and applause]
Twenty seconds, Blake!
- Yes!
- Uh, this is--
it's money, and it's--
and if you--if you--
- Don't show her!
- I'm not, but if I bend over,
and you put the money--
- What is happening?
[laughter]
- It's 5¢.
How much is 5¢?
What is 5¢?
- If you bend over,
you put the money--
- What is 5?
- What are you talking about?
- What is he talking about?
What are you talking about?
You lost your mind!
- I'm talking about Nickelback.
- Nickelback?
- 5¢.
Nickelback.
- Oh, my God.
- Nickel, bend over--
- I'm sorry.
What is he talking about?
You've lost your mind.
- I was really distracted
by you doing that. I'm sorry.
- Oh, my gosh. Like,
this is a prime time show.
You can't do that.
- People were talking
about laid.
What kind of a show is this?
[laughter]
- John, you got 5,000 points.
Kelly and John got the win
on that one.
Let's play one more round.
Now look, get your mind
out of the gutter!
The category here
is house music, okay?
- Don't let 'em mess with you,
Ari.
- All of these artists have
names
that sound like things
you'd find around the house.
- Oh.
- Okay.
- All right. Ariana, you're
going to start this off--
- Oh, I got one. I hope--
- Let's get the records
in position.
Really, you know already?
- I think. I think.
- All right. Ready?
On your mark, get set, go.
Good luck.
- Okay. Okay, these are
the entrances
and the exits of the house,
and you need to open
and close them.
- The Doors.
- Yeah!
- That was so confident,
and I loved that.
- All right.
This is half of a dollar.
- 50 Cent!
- Yeah!
[cheers and applause]
- That's not something that--
- Go! Hurry up.
- This is a tool
that you use to--
- Hammer, nail.
Nails and hammers.
Nine Inch Nails.
I don't know.
- Oh, my god, Ariana.
No, no, no, no you--
- Help me. What--
- You can't touch this!
- What?
- Two and two--
- Oh, MC Hammer!
Oh, my God.
- Oh, that was unbelievable.
He did it!
Blake and Ariana
won that round.
That was unfair.
That was unbelievable.
Very good.
That was The Vinyl Countdown.
We're going to take
a quick break.